[Musique]
sa bombe sa coupe sapin à la patinoire
d'orléans les artistes du douar show
travaille dur pour finaliser leurs
oeuvres
et cette année le public aura double
ration de créations originales des
fresques et des installations
j'aime bien la peinture baroque mais
j'aime bien la déconnade aussi donc
j'essaie de mélanger un petit peu
l'austérité de la peinture classique ou
à l'humour une certaine forme de
légèreté un frigo revisité a investi la
piste de la patinoire des gelées pour
l'occasion boîtes de céréales briques de
lait canettes de bière et là sont
fondues en art optique on joue beaucoup
avec les trames noires et blanches parce
que il ya quelque chose d'assez agressif
à l'oeil et moi ce que je joue justement
avec
avec ses formes là en plus en opposant
un travail sur le fractal et le côté
organique qui va être créée justement
dans cette flaque d'eau grâce à l'étagé
du dessous ce sont les fresques qui
accroche l'oeil
ici trois artistes berlinois ont été
invités habiller les murs
riot évidament ont déjà apposé leur
signature on sent très bien très
facilement le mélange entre toutes ces
références graffiti et ses références
comics bandes dessinées il arrive à
vraiment faire des trucs très très faim
un petit motif de vêtements tous les
plis tu vois qui rendent un petit rendu
un petit peu classique et sa manière de
travailler en crash aux tic comme ça ils
arrivent à l'exploiter pour faire
vraiment quelque chose de très figuratif
ce qui nous plaît dans son travail c'est
que lui il est dans un souci du détail
et de la propreté mois pour moi là pour
la plupart des gens on n'est plus du
tout dans ce qu'ils entendent par art
urbain aussi une toile géante quoi le
festival des arts urbains dans les
environs à ses portes vendredi 11 juin
prochain pour deux week-ends consécutifs
avec au programme live painting et dj
set pour célébrer l'été de la plus douce
des manières